[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir la joie vos regards vous êtes en
train de vous dire tiens il ya eu un
désistement par fo
alors en fait le césar du meilleur
montage devait être remis par l'immense
réalisateur chinois sierra que nous
connaissons tous ici bien sûr qui a
tourné entre autres l'odeur de la bande
bleue l'avant dernier empereur père le
coco de biopic des frères tang a pu bien
sûr la dernière campagne leroy merlin
faut bien bouffer ou sais ce que c'est
giran a atterri à roissy à 18 heures
mais sa valise et à düsseldorf
donc là l'heure qu'il est doit être aux
réclamations de china airlines en train
de gueuler en bermuda sans lui faire
injure je pense qu'on peut le considérer
comme absents
d'où ma présence alors oui j'ai
peut-être pas sans succès mais moi mes
fringues sont ma penderie plus sûrement
appelé plus tôt j'aurais fait un petit
régime je me serai remis à la zumba je
danse à bon train 18h et 20h30 question
de perdre une dent non enfin moi je me
formalise pas pour ses appels de
dernière minute parce que ça peut donner
des choses formidables dans dernier film
dans lequel j'ai tourné d'ailleurs
heureusement que le comédien qui devait
avoir le rôle a perdu sa mère sinon le
film passé en corse où venait à ce
propos j'en profite pour dire aux
producteurs réalisateurs qui sont dans
la salle si vous avez un comédien qu'à
une semaine du tournage vous sentez un
peu fébriles un peu souffreteux otites
cholestérol afin d'aider truc grave
le gac aurait eu un bilan moyen moyen
chez zuccarelli par exemple à l'époque
je ne donne pas mon téléphone est une
question de principe mais en revanche
vous pouvez le joindre sur mon courriel
gg la tornade at club tiré du cices
internet.fr mais contactez moi avant 18
heures un signe après oui eh bien je
vais bâclé